okay hello everyone we are back doing
more language design reviews this is a
language
completeness and consistency
meeting our first topic is propagate
aborts
right so you should open the new rough
page and actually there are probably
some others we should take at least a
quick look at but
and i committed this last night around
between 2 and 3 a.m so
okay so we might not it's probably not
in my version yet
oh
yep it's there
okay
how does this relate okay
i know we talked about this before but i
don't remember all the details of what
point was
right so there's this issue of when you
call check abort
um do you
you know
does checkboard swallow
the abort and it's no longer to be seen
anywhere or does it persist past the
chat report
and the the behavior we've had up till
now is that if it's a user abort as in
you hit control c or
there's an explicit call to a board
um or you select a board from the
interrupt menu
then check abort swallows that abort and
it
goes on its merry way
but if you do a memory constrained or
time constrained
then the abort persists past the check
abort so you can
react to the abort inside of
the memory constrained but
you still
you might still want the
evaluation to actually stop so you
persist the abort so yeah i think it was
worse than what you're saying etai i
think it was buggy and did not even
abort
inside you know time constrained would
would not properly abort inside check
abort if i remember correctly look i
don't understand abort protect is like
propagating our boards correct
no
okay why not
uh because
abort
says don't allow any aborts in this
thing to be
uh
activated to be activated while this
code run this run
calls to completion
now they can still be raised
right
so at the end they will they will split
out
so correct
um
and then in
so check abort
right even a checkerboard even inside of
an abort protect will detect those
supports and react to them
and then the question is does the check
abort
allow
that
abort to persist or does it not allow it
to persist i get it
how does this relate to con confirming
close and its conventions for
propagation
um let me christopher comment on that
uh i think about that um
right so i think i mean that confirm and
close are sort of more analogous to
uh throw catch right and so
you know when you throw it's like you
know do not pass go do not collect 200
go directly to
catch um
and um i mean i suppose there are
possibly a couple of exceptions to that
but that's more or less the idea but the
catch and the catch does not propagate
then
right once it's caught then
it's done
so the checkerboard with no propagation
will be the analog of a catch
correct
whereas
so that would be probably the boards
goes to false
yeah you'd have to maybe have a nested
throw
to be analogous to a propagation of one
level how does that work if i say throw
of throw do i have to say catch a catch
to catch you
i mean if you give second arguments
i think it's worse than that i think you
have to do throw of unevaluated throw in
order to need a second catch that's
probably true yeah i think having throat
throw throw the inner throw will just
run but but i think that the um
right i mean actually there's been some
uh
there were some uses and some error
handling contexts where i mean maybe
this is only for fairly niche internal
stuff but but where uh it would be nice
to have stuff for basically propagating
throws as well i mean basically where
you want it so that you have a throw and
then you have a catch that looks at it
and then makes a decision about whether
or not this throw is relevant to it and
if it isn't relevant it just throws it
again i don't think it makes sense to
have an actual construct for that but
it's a similar flow rate
and what about by the way there's an
error there's a spelling mistake here
memory
okay well i can fix that you know i know
you could fix that i'm just pointing it
out since i noticed it okay there's a
different case which is the propagation
in the event handler right event handler
has some kind of propagation of events
thing does it not
right
but i think that's a little different
because with event handler what's
happening
is just because you're interested in a
mouse event
doesn't mean
that
you should prevent other things that are
interested in mouse events from seeing
them
whereas
throw
right either either the inner catch
grabs it or it doesn't
it's not that the inner catch
is going to
do something
and it's not doing anything because
um the code flow is going to
then even out or more one
okay but so this notion of past events
down past events up is irrelevant
the things we're talking about here is
that correct i think so
at least at least
my mental model of these things doesn't
include it and maybe there's something
funny about
uh that that you could think about with
the third argument to catch which would
contradict me
but
okay
i'm not seeing it
okay i mean this seems like
okay so time constraint also has that
so time constrained
do we do we say that time constraint
generates an abort do we say that's how
it works yes we do we do and that's not
entirely true so you'll see a note and
then beneath it a tentative note which
is
basically
uh
replacing uh you know cutting out the
the not true part at a time constrained
aboard that the time constraint board is
exactly the same as the normal abort i
mean that's just never been true and i
don't think i thought that we changed it
so that it was true you tried um i could
be wrong
well it's clearly not in check abort
right i mean checkerboard behaves
differently um yeah okay yes that was
for a few reasons including backward
compatibility but if you make if you set
propagator boards to false i believe it
is then the same
so yes it's the non-default setting
and that was by intent uh aft you know
discussion with roman and others
right
yes i mean it took us literally years of
discussion to
to settle on on this design um
which design
so that the default is that the default
behavior of check abort is that
you know what we internally call abort
aborts are
are
swallowed but that
time aborts and memory aborts are
propagated
okay so wait a minute so what is the
change that you're what was the proposed
change
to time constrained
it's really just the wording
right so rather than saying that uh
aborts generated by time constrained are
treated exactly like those generated by
abort
it's to just say that aborts generated
by time constraint can be fine
yeah
okay
right i think this seems reasonable
anybody anybody else want to complain or
anything with this
it seems reasonable for now i mean i can
imagine some even more elaborate
abort control thing but i think it's one
of these things where you know as i've
said multiple times and i hope we're
going to restart these these some
message handling meetings you know you
have the primary code path where nothing
goes wrong and there are no aborts there
are no messages there are no errors
and then we've got the secondary code
path where something where one thing
goes wrong by the time we're at the
quaternary code part
where two different aborts happen that
intertwined with themselves
you know we're dealing with a very
obscure case
and i think this is what we've got here
is a reasonable handling of what one
might call the secondary code part that
involves a single abort and you know how
it's how it's handled is that a
reasonable analysis or
i think so i mean
i mean right this also comes up with
like i mean the reason roman was
involved right is distributed computing
right you might want to
somehow communicate these right you have
this code
that and you need to distinguish between
the parts of the thing that's running
the code and the user code and and so
you know there are uses for this
something more elaborate yeah it's
i think i think we have a sense of what
will happen but sort of customizing
we i don't see an obvious use for it
right
um
okay well fair enough
uh okay seems reasonable so should we go
on okay
system exception
oh my god what is this
i'm
curious if why oh are you in thirteen
one maybe i'm i'm a bit
confused by why it weighs
thirteen one it's a it's a recent
shipping version now okay
so well that explains why
that output looks kind of funny right so
i mean we talked about this in the
spring
um
and uh
and we decided not to do anything for 13
1 and the question is do we want to do
something for 13 too
right so we have what is the question
exactly correct so the question is
how to handle
um
uh you know running into recursion limit
and
uh iteration limit so right now we issue
a message
and we try to
uh
return some sort of
you know partially evaluated thingamabob
and
the idea is that we should instead just
you know generate an exception and
you know
indicate that i should add that as
currently configured in our evaluator we
are not always successful in returning
this partially evaluated thingamabob
even inside a hold
sometimes we um end up going back into
recursion we have crashes from this all
over not all over but several bug
reports
i think this is again a story of a sort
of the quaternary code path and so on
you know it's it's like first there was
an error then there was an error to the
error and so on yeah yeah that that's
that's what causes the
recursion
type problems to you know when they
crash it's because of those i wouldn't
call it quaternary
tertiary maybe yeah okay right fine
as opposed to transfinitely infinite
towers right
right
yeah as opposed to that uh that wasn't
the first thing that came to mind but
yeah
although if i suppose if you really
wanted to do it consistently for
everything it really would be a
transfinite tower
that's right
right i mean and so the question really
here is how close are we to the
possibility i mean this is the circular
data structures infinite data structures
story
and you know in the next few years are
we actually going to get those because
if we are
then many of these things will turn into
one of these bizarre transfinite data
structures
i'm not convinced of that
i i think mcniel may be the example
we're looking at here but i i still
think we're going to run into um
recursion stack issues and uh
less common but the iteration limit
which is really
reevaluation
sort of misnamed i think we still run
into both of those even with infinite
data structures
well you're right an infinite data
structure is just a representation of a
simple case
and there's no guarantee that these are
being generated in a simple way they
could be generated in some incredibly
complicated way yeah right i mean it's
like at the touring machine that just
wiggles its head back and forth
and that can be represented as a sort of
just a loop of some kind
so yes i agree that the um
i mean okay you can no more foresee the
infinite data you know the infinite
loop as you can foresee the whole thing
of the whole thing in general so there
can be you know again we're we're
submerging into this sort of marsh of
complexity that there can be a case in
which it is you know
generating
random gunk
infinitely so to speak as opposed to
just looping infinitely where it where
there's a you know it's like we can
represent infinity by just a symbol
but we can't represent these infinite
structures in an easy way i mean or we
could like you know our basic data
structure is a tree but if we allowed it
to be a dag we could represent a bunch
of these infinite things i think
it is a dag
our basic data structure it's the um
acyclicity that
you know kind of prevents that
infiniteness well but it's it's secretly
a dag because it's a copy on right kind
of thing so it doesn't actually behave
like a tag
yes okay
in in any case
if it's a cyclic
it's not going to
have that capacity for representing
infinite structures
although you can with unevaluated stuff
or like with whole dolls ah yeah yeah
true because you can have expressions
that contain themselves yeah
so there's ways to do it with as a side
remark with that so what's the question
what's the question
whether or not to re-enable uh to enable
this as default handling
where um
a system exception gets thrown rather
than uh
allowing for the current behavior right
can it limp after it's been
recursioned out is basically the
question or do we just or is it is it
euthanased or something
rather than limping
i i i prefer that that ladder because
years ago i actually made some changes
which allowed it to limp more frequently
than just cause crashes
but it's
with this limping it is impossible to
stop it from just getting back into
trouble
yes i i also i generally think that
limping is if you know that something's
gone wrong limping is is bad but but
maybe actually i mean here's a naive
question what is even the purpose of
recursion limited iteration limit
to avoid
to write it running at least in in
ancient operating systems i don't know
what's the case today
but back 35 years ago if you ran out of
stack space it just crashed
and there was nothing you could do about
it
there wasn't others
but but when you make a function call in
mathematica is it actually i mean it's
not like the arguments of that function
call are actually stored in the stack
but they are the evaluator is actually
recursing on the stack
yeah any anytime you go into the i eval
evaluation loop um
you're using recursion uh in in the seat
um right yeah it's actually working
because it's about a factor of 10
right because we have 10 functions we
call to do one function call
it might not be
it might not be 10 but it's at least
five
yeah so what is the
just out of uh maybe if someone knows
off the top of their head because i know
that like at least a few years ago when
i was looking this on on mac it was like
i think 16 megabytes one six megabytes
was the default stack size so i mean how
deep does that let you go
typically uh on on linux machines that
at least the ones i've worked on you get
maybe 60 000 um
deep on the subroutine stack maybe
for these for the eye of our calls or
for
no no i mean 60 000 calls complete you
know all together which means if i eval
is every fifth
or so then you know divide by five
twelve thousand yeah but right so i mean
in
okay back in the day
you know
we let malloc just allocate away heap
memory
for expressions and we took the
principle that the system should just
keep doing that until it rounded memory
you're reminding me what the issue was
the issue is picks stack size
allocations in operating systems
because even though the stack is going
down like a stalactite or something
you know it typically they they don't
allocate that they still don't allocate
dynamics right and and and
i'm not even sure you want that that
um
i mean yeah if you have more memory
available it might be nice but
yeah
things have gone badly
generally speaking you've gotten there
it's gone badly wrong yeah exactly
you're not likely to save yourself in
many situations you're more it's more
likely your code had a problem already
well what about what about is iteration
limit the same problem or or is that i
think it doesn't require it doesn't so
that can
cause it but yeah there are other
reasons that we get into
um
uh infinite reevaluation tail recursion
is one reason yes
right i'm just thinking of i mean some
of the for example we had a summer
school student this year who is doing
some things with uh you know infinite
data you know infinite self-referential
data structures so where you know they
have a hold all argument and they
contain themselves and stuff like that
and one of the issues was that uh
you could run into cases where you'd hit
the recursion i forget it was the
recursion or the iteration limit but it
didn't seem like there was any
fundamental reason why
you know it would you know in some of
these cases you understand why you know
oh yes it really needs to store all this
information in the stack in order for it
to work but there were cases where it
didn't seem like there was any
fundamental reason why anything needed
to be stored in the stack and so i i'm
just wondering if uh
well right in those cases whether the
recursion limit is sort of an arbitrary
uh
you know an arbitrary description right
i think the recursion limit and it would
one would have to look at the code to
know but i think the recursion limit is
uh
sort of separate instrumentation
not
directly related to actually seeing
memory build up on the stack
it's related to subroutine call count
though
and i think that is directly related
okay i mean denies what chris was saying
right
you you you for recursion
iteration right iteration limit right
the problem is
yeah i mean i i suppose that
uh
i'm well i think it's mostly just that
probably if if
if you've gone on long enough you've
probably gotten yourself into a loop
um but i mean that's going to be heap
exhaustion not stack extra
exhaustion if if it exactly
resource that it would be heap yes right
but but there's a general no i mean we
usually don't care about keep exhaustion
if i make a table with you know a
hundred trillion elements it'll try and
do it and fail right i mean it'll just
eat up all my memory
right well you'll you'll get as long as
100
as long as 100 trillion is less than two
to the 63rd right because it won't okay
fine to the 63 minus one or something
well you'll you'll get a a malloc will
give you trouble but if you try to do
this like one at a time like you're you
know creating a linked list or something
um
hard to say for what what will happen
maybe eventually
yeah that's true right
just like here eventually the stack will
be overrun and you'll crash
am i remembering correctly that it was
actually even worse than that back in
the day when we originally implemented
this that actually the operating system
would crash
i'm not sure i
it's interesting
entirely possible with the operating
systems of the early 90s that
you know you know you could uh
you know consume enough of the stack
that the colonel would go wonky and
crash yeah i know the commodore 64 stack
would just wrap around and overwrite
itself
all right yeah that's your possibility
that we've made
yeah it's possible we've made an advance
since the cover 64. thankfully
i've just repressed too many memories of
that era so i can't tell you what
happened then
okay but the the concrete question here
is should i mean
there are cases where
i mean i kind of wonder whether we
should have a recursion constrained
function because right now you can say
block dollar recursion limit equals blah
right yep
and
but i don't trust that because i think
it's going to limp after i after it
fails from that
but what i can imagine being useful
is let's say you get one of these system
exceptions
okay you've got a list of evaluations
going on you know you're computing
acumen functions or something i don't
know what
and
you know you've got the first four and
they work fine and you've got one that
blows up
it's annoying that the whole thing just
returns blip you know system exception
you're you're dead you don't know even
where it happened
remember making sense yeah that is a a
drawback
um still think it's better than the
options but but it is a known drawback
to the system exception
right i mean also there's another point
to make here which is there's pieces of
the evaluation that were successfully
completed before the recursion limit was
hit
yeah and yet you're not returning those
well i mean in a way it's like your own
damn fault you know use catch
it's throwing a system exception and and
i think the message says you can use it
with catch too
there's there's one of the issues that's
that's very irritating is that
that you know so this this does a so so
you can't put a you can't easily just
put a
it would be nice if we could just have a
tagless catch catch any of these things
but they don't
so you have to know to catch a system
exception
well you know because because i don't
think you want generic catch to do it
because then
something i mean then you could have
some totally bizarre thing happening in
code
that that you've got to catch there for
some completely different reason but you
blow up the stack
and then your catch catches it and
everybody's confused
so i don't i don't object to the fact
that this is a not default
not defaultly catchable thing but look
what i'm suggesting well no it is
catchable
no div not default catchable oh
well the default um is is the thing that
is crashable
crash prone i know
so let me and let me just point out that
that uh
you know that formatting there right
that's make boxes actually catching the
the system exception and saying
right and that you know you can use that
as input it will interpret correctly
it'll just uh
you know it just says well you know
rather than pinking or crashing it's
just like well big boxes ran into
trouble so i can't display it but your
result is safe with me
so you know you can all i'm saying is
you can't do something
uh what you're saying i could say depth
or something there on that object and i
would get a reasonable answer yes
but that thing is very
incendiary i mean it's a little it's a
little
you know recursion bomb or something but
the thing that you get out from
recursion limit
has extended itself right out to the
limits of recurs recursive ability so to
speak and if you fed it into something
else it would blow up
no no no no because it's the make boxes
rule that blew up
right so
if if you get give it to depth it'll
give you zero or one whatever it is that
that will give you um because g is fine
yeah okay so your point here is i see i
haven't really understood this this is
recursion blowing up inside the
formatter
exactly the evaluator right exactly
and that that actually is uh i think a
separate issue etai you and i discussed
with some ideas about maybe um
scaling that that back by changing top
of that a little bit
yeah but but i think not for 13-2
well i also think that i mean i think
that's
somewhat orthogonal so we've got two
different issues one is
do we
as soon as we hit a recursion limit do
we blow out with a system exception and
generally return to top level unless
somebody put in a specific catch
or
do we do what we're currently doing
which is to attempt to limp on with
evaluation
and you're saying
what i'm saying is that what if there's
a system exception then make boxes can
catch it and do something sensible
which
recursion limit that's right
okay right so so you've got two
different things one is the wrapper
blew up and the other is the thing
itself blew up
the first case you're showing here where
the actual evaluation itself generated a
recursion limit which potentially goes
to a system exception is different from
the case where the attempt to display
that thing generated the system error
generally
right but my point is make right make
boxes goes through the evaluator right
after you're done i get it i get it it's
a secondary possible evaluation
right
and there are other secondary evaluators
as well right and and and because
there's now a system exception make
boxes can catch those and you know do
something sensible in the case where
that passed through the evaluator
produced a recursion limit terror
well i mean i thought the thing being
fed to make boxes if the actual
expression is a system exception
then make boxes will just get there
there is no
no no no there's no system exception
i mean right you can type in system
exception right system exception has no
formatting rules i mean you can see that
in the previous output
the point is that
their um system exception is generated
while make boxes is formatting g
and so rather than peak boxing or
crashing the kernel or various other bad
things make boxes says oh look i caught
the system exception let me return this
template box which doesn't display the
expression yeah i get it i get it but
that's an exception generated during
formatting and i agree with you that the
thing you're doing here is pretty much
the obvious thing to do rather than pink
boxing or crashing i agree with that the
question is the different question is
whether the inner whether whether the
correct behavior if you have a list of
things one of which hits a recursion
limit but the other ones do not
whether what you want to return is one
comma two comma three comma recursion
limit thingy hell hold whatever whether
you want to just say boom you are out of
luck the whole thing returns system
exception
right
and right obviously you could
right you could make that the first
thing happen by right if you your table
has no
right
but i i'm i'm saying
i think that will be good to happen by
default which is what's been happening
for 35 years or whatever
right so basically you're suggesting the
table would automatically have a catch
no i i don't i don't see how this works
steven you
once you start limping i mean you're
basically dead in the water and you're
saying well we should return what we
already computed
you know partial results
and
yeah i mean i think it's a different
no no no you you've got an expression
tree
you have been reconstructing an
expression tree you are in the evaluator
you are
recursing
something
blows up
in the evaluator okay you're at element
four and in going through a list because
the evaluators essentially go through a
list
okay you haven't done the other elements
well if you're in the r if you've hit
recursion
limit
what's going to happen is you're going
to have this deeply nested expression
that you're returning with a hold around
it
and so you're you're just going to go
right back into the recursion
uh when you know if you try to for
instance print it out
even if you don't
um you're you're
no i agree with you i actually have this
this huge yeah i know taking this this
exploded object
and returning it is asking for trouble
right the question is only whether it
whether basically it causes an explosion
that causes everything you're evaluating
to disappear or whether it is merely
this particular thing it's like you know
the titanic or something but how how do
you delimit that thing
you're you're in a table and you've
evaluated three elements yeah how far do
you know
yeah exactly so so okay fine so that's
why i'm saying you need to put in that
catch explicitly
if you know something your argument is
deep in the depths of recursion the
whole thing just went infinitely
and the question is do you have a i
don't know what did they call them you
know in the titanic or something do you
have the the compartment you know thing
that you can close to prevent right
right right you we we don't have a way
of demarcating these compartments
other than um
exclusive catches yes
exactly
okay
so that's the issue so the issue is
this is by the way it's very related to
i mean
i i haven't heard about this in a while
but i mean there was all that stuff in
the error handling working group things
about some proposal for sort of a more
generalized uh
kind of exception
system that i mean if that ever gets
implemented then long term that's that's
like
that's how this should should work
basically
what's happened to that error handling
discussion
hey we're supposed to send out a
proposal shortly after thirteen one
release and they haven't so
so somebody needs to be bugged there
about that
um
but
okay to me this is not fully cooked i
mean this is a complicated problem and a
very interesting problem and a problem
that relates both the error handling and
to infinite data structure questions
but i i mean i do understand the issue i
think now basically the point is
something went bad the thing went off
infinitely it will eventually blow
itself up and run out of memory
fortunately we've instrumented it to the
point where we know that's about to
happen and we stop it
but
once stopped
i mean you see the way one would do this
okay
you know again this is this is different
layers of pumping out sea water so to
speak
um
okay you know clearly it's like when you
have a memory allocator and you give it
some headroom and you say you know have
the program start to exit when you are
at 90 memory allocation
if you see what i mean in other words be
allocating ahead of where you need and
if you start seeing malloc returns no
then
back out and give yourself a certain
amount of headroom for your escape path
so to speak we kind of try that it
doesn't work so well but we kind of try
that now
you say we try it
we do try it in terms of the the
error messaging
okay but i mean so so what i'm saying
here is we could imagine a situation
where
yes you have
the basic problem is the code path in
which the recursion limit has been hit
is not a stable code path it's not a
well explored code part
i have no idea what tests have been done
on it
you know i don't know if you have a a
largely recursioned out expression and
you feed it to find shortest tour or
something what the heck does it do
that making sense
but i could imagine in a horrible pump
out the sea water kind of scenario you
could say
this is a bad idea but i'm going to say
it anyway once you've hit that limit
you could have a thing that kind of lets
out like one of those suitcases that has
extra you know it has an extra thing
that allows it to be an inch
you know taller if you really need it to
be um you know once once you hit that
limit you let out the stops and allow it
to go a little bit further in the hopes
that it will successfully limp its way
out we kind of
that's kind of our default now i believe
not exactly like that but
at least for recovering from the error
we
try to reinitialize
um you know the recursion limit to back
it out
and we're i don't think we're doing it
very well that's what i was you know
that side track with etai
several minutes ago was kind of related
to that
um
where we could improve it but but it's
not that we don't do this at all
we we actually do i think
this is a truly complicated issue i mean
look i think your point about make boxes
returning a you're out of luck
that seems fine to me
this question about whether
we return
boy what about the possibility
is there anything incendiary about the
expression itself if we froze it
completely which is what we're trying to
do right now is the expression itself
incendiary
um if you try to evaluate it or print it
yes otherwise i don't think so
okay but so if it was encapsulated in a
in a failure exception type object
and you had the whole thing there
okay the other thing i mean again this
is a pumping out sea water kind of kind
of scenario but the other thing one
could do
is keep it in us in the failure object
and simply try and chop its tail off
so in other words you look at the
expression and you shallow it so to
speak you say anything deeper than such
and such an amount just chop it off
and then you put that expression in some
kind of hold
and you say this is probably going to be
safe
well what if we put in one of these
inert expression things
which inert expression things well the
one the
data structure
the
well
that tom set up that's that's completely
inert so you could you can examine it
with a loop for example look at the you
know brighter loop that goes to the
heads that's not actually recurs
recursing right
so i do i do have a question about all
this though
where
you're you've hit this recursion limit
and um
you're you're coming back up i guess for
what for air
um how you i mean when you hit it you're
at the bottom it's not as though you
have access to the
to the depth and all that you're
i know i know i know i know so i'm not
sure how this is perfect okay so here's
the point you hit it
and it says we're done here you've got
to just come back up okay
but
what i would suggest i don't know
exactly the implementation but let's say
you come back up
you don't know the depth it doesn't
really matter you don't know the depth
if you come back up
and you are
you know this is again a headroom kind
of idea you're down at the depths
you say you hit the bottom you can't go
any further now you recurse back up
you go 50 levels of recursion back up
and you say i'm going to chop off that
50 levels below me that tail that's 50
levels below me and i'm going to put
some recursion end marker in there and
then i'm going to come back up
telling the system that i hit a i hit a
you know i hit the bottom of the
recursion limit
see what i'm saying
i think this is not a completely stupid
way to handle it in other words what you
end up with is a safe expression
where you are you hit the bottom but
then there's a secondary you know
recursion
you know a back off a recursion back off
number which says given that you hit the
bottom you back off let's say you halve
the recursion down
and you insert there a plug at the end
of this thing that says we're not going
to go any further here
you put in you put in that
you you you cap off the the deep
drilling thing or whatever and you you
just say this is the end and then as you
come back up you say i hit a you know i
hit trouble down there
now the fact is if you've cauterized i
think i think i think a more sensible
solution is you get to the bottom you
convert what you have there
to a data in their data structure and
right then that's what it evaluated to
when you work your way back up
right you know assuming that conversion
to a data structure
is safe and doesn't take a respect
through the evaluator
then
that's possible and it's possible i mean
i think that's nice but i think it's
slightly unnecessary i mean i think
you're providing
a you're giving too much that's the
person who hasn't looked at all the bugs
of when things go wrong because we try
to return this you know what we have
wrapped in holes so i mean i think i
think that you know i think what you're
thinking about stephen is is great you
know and and but but the number of cases
where people would actually use it is is
i know but i'm saying you're really
sorry okay listen listen i'm saying you
cut the tail off
as far as you want to cut it off to the
point where you're sure it's safe
you wrap it in hold and you return it
and then
yes you're right you're losing some
information because it actually went a
lot further it actually recurs further
you're not storing that later recursion
because you know it's not safe to store
the whole thing
at least not as an ordinary expression
what you're proposing is
converting to an inert expression which
i'm not you know which i think is fairly
confusing to people i think that most
people hit this i mean i know i've hit
this a bunch of times and it's just like
oh i just had to go a little bit further
oh that's annoying sometimes i even
increase the recursion limit
um
and uh
uh you know and it just makes it through
if i increase the recursion
um
and
but i mean i'd be perfectly happy if it
just said
you know it ran out of recursion room on
this element element seven out recursed
itself
and then element eight keeps going and
so on and so on and so on and i'm just
written returning this blob that
represents a i went too far
because the thing doesn't hurt itself
right when it's at the bottom when it's
hit the recursion limit no no damage has
occurred at that point
it's it's protected itself from damage
the only place where there's damage is
returning that big thing which might
then be reinspected so just don't return
the big thing just cauterize that big
thing chop its tail off
does that make sense
well say you're in a nested table
construct
that that ends up being infinitely
nested you know where where do you
which which point do you
yes you can arbitrarily say i'm gonna go
back up you know three quarters of the
recursion stack or something like that
but
well how do we do it right now we stop
at some point so i see i
don't know how we unwind i i agree i
don't know how we unwind and i don't and
we didn't put in checkpoints so we don't
i don't know how far we have to unwind
i admit that
and
you know i i still argue for a function
recursion constrained that would control
this stuff a little bit more
and where recursion constrained
like time constrained you know is just
the way of
of uh you know is it what we could even
think about is that our default
you know just like right now
it's called recursion constraint and i
would expect it to generate an abort
exactly and then you'd have to catch it
with with checkerboard or whatever yeah
right but what i'm saying is
yes what i'm saying is right now the
main loop
has no time constraint no memory
constraint by default we could give it
those people could give it those i'm
saying the main loop effectively however
has a recursion constraint with dollar
recursion limits in it
i'm saying maybe we should make that
explicit
well
that can be done you know in the hacky
way of using block dollar sign recursion
limit equals whatever
i'm not sure okay we've had a useful
discussion about this i i my feeling is
that it i understand your point we don't
know how far to unroll
yeah
i think this requires a bit more thought
but i do agree that your thing about
what to do with the print
you know printing is reasonable but can
that be done without solving this other
problem
no it can't because you have to have
this encapsulated system exception
before you can do that
yep yep
we need to discuss this more i'm sorry
this is not um
i don't think we've solved this yet
sorry
can we do the with one because that one
should be very short
i didn't
didn't know that worked
i don't think uh anybody else did either
um
lou
found it by accident and asked when was
it by intent
probably a long long time ago looking at
that code
like 30 years ago or something could be
yeah this could very well
date the version too i mean i've not
gone back and tested it but
yeah i i suspect it does looking at the
code and comments it looked like it was
actually designed to do just this
shoot
this isn't bad it just what it's it's
doing i mean maybe it's obvious to you
but it's just not evaluating val
um
prior to the assignment
cool
so it actually works harder
at the beginning at least when when it's
set versus set delay
is it delayed
yeah yeah right but if you do x colon
equals random real
um it'll keep re-evaluating
yeah
i presumably if you do that it's what
you wanted
presumably
all right
um
i've seen francisco using this
repeatedly
this thing here yeah yeah
he told me
long ago yeah
i don't know i just tested that it works
in version three i don't have version
two handy but i suspect that like i said
i suspect it goes back to version two it
could go back to one couldn't it yeah no
with was new and oh width was new okay
this is the point about returning
what is the point here returning a
modern
region object or something
right well yes i mean it's one of those
things where you sent out an email with
a subject line and no
content and expect us to read your mind
and even though i think i'm pretty smart
i can't actually read your mind so yeah
all right some of the comments and tried
to figure out
some useful discussion points
to say about this
yeah i mean i i've i've complained about
this several times although although i
had a
useful discussion with jose about this
in person i mean basically
the issue is is
you know if you ask for for instance the
uh here it's the the polygon for the
world and it gives you this geo group
filled curve etc etc object
um
the problem is is that there are
standard functions using geogrid
position and boundary discretized region
for converting between
geo regions and uh and regions that can
be you know computed with the problem is
that these funky objects
right now can't be converted into
regions and so that's so there are two
solutions i think over email the idea is
to maybe do both
one of them is to be able to
you know one get the ability to to run
something like boundary discretize
region on some weird filled curve like
this
um
the other thing was
really the g i think it's really the geo
group that's the problem right i don't
think that filled curve no the filled
curve is also a problem
but but the geode both of them are
problems so so that that that's one part
the the other part i mean there's also
the fact that you'd have to run geogrid
position around this and i don't think
geogrid position is smart enough to
burrow its way all the way into all
those geo positions
um
but but the other issue is just and this
is a more complicated issue um it would
be great if something like this returned
something nice and modern like a
geopolygon but then apparently the
problem is that you know right now
there's no versioning when you call you
know entity value
when the server responds it has no idea
what version of mathematically you're
using so if you're using a version older
than the latest version yeah that's not
true
that's not true
yes i've also learned recently from
francisco that it it can be done yeah
so we could return to your polygon in
more recent versions
that that i don't know but um well why
not
well well because i don't know how you i
don't know how you would form it but but
it's not it's not right so long as the
server can be taught how to return
geopolygon it can return geopolygon to
people that can use it and while
returning the old thing to people who
can't use it
no problem here
yeah so i mean the only issue is how it
makes the geopolygon even though it
might not yet know about geopolygons on
the server because it might be running
an older version exactly
okay
but i think it can yeah okay
all right we should wrap up here
good stuff
we have to come back to this this topic
about system exceptions next time okay
okay see y'all soon